prohibición de la hiyab en centros
educativos una medida que produce
malestar niños en las ciudades de
calcuta y generaban cientos de
estudiantes se unieron a las protestas
de las jóvenes en sureño estado de
karnataka califican el veto como un acto
de islamofobia
[Aplausos]
este gobierno islamófobo está tratando
de negar nuestro derecho queremos
nuestros derechos y libertades y
lucharemos por ellos hasta el último
minuto de nuestra vida
seguiremos protestando hasta que el
gobierno deje de insultar a los
estudiantes queremos que nos devuelvan
nuestros derechos fundamentales
la semana pasada varias universidades en
el estado negaron la entrada a niñas
musulmanas que usaban el hijab citando
una orden del gobierno de educación
esta estudiante musulmana se enfrentó a
una multitud que gritaba consignas
hindúes a favor de la restricción
el mes pasado se ordenó a los
estudiantes de una escuela secundaria
pública en el estado de karnataka que no
usaran el hijab en los terrenos
escolares otras escuelas públicas
también se sumaron a uno de los centros
educativos que prohibió el velo se
retractó parcialmente permitiendo que
sus estudiantes musulmanas regresarán a
clases pero con la condición de que se
sienten en aulas separadas la minoría
musulmana del país dice ser cada vez más
objeto de persecución por parte del
gobierno nacionalista al cual pertenece
el primer ministro narendra modi el
tribunal superior de karnataka escuchará
una petición en el caso para determinar
si frena la medida entre tanto el estado
ordenó el cierre de escuelas
universidades durante tres días
intentando frenar las protestas